all
379 passengers in crew on board a Japan
Airlines jet managed to escape after a
collision on a Runway at haneda airport
in Tokyo on Tuesday the passenger plane
was engulfed in flames soon after
crashing with a Coast Guard Plane five
of the six crew members on the smaller
Jets died but the nearly full Airbus
a350 Jets managed to evacuate safely in
under 20 minutes but there were lots of
things about that aircraft that that
helped to protect the passengers here
are some of the factors that led to this
successful
evacuation at 5:47 p.m. on Tuesday Japan
Airlines flight 516 an Airbus a350 900
traveling from Sao in Northern Japan to
Tokyo collided with a Coast Guard Plane
JL 516 was burning on the
outside but crucially it was not yet
burning on the inside side and so the
race to save its passengers
started the way an evacuation usually
proceeds is that once the plane has come
to a standstill the flight crew usually
give the command to the cabin crew to
initiate the evacuation and the flight
deck will normally tell the cabin crew
which side or which exits they can
use Japan Airlines said it took some
time to get the doors open because
flight attendants first needed the
Pilot's confirmation that the airplane
had come to a complete stop and they
needed to check whether it was safe to
evacuate to operate around the world
aircraft manufacturers must prove to
Regulators that passengers can evacuate
a plane in 90 seconds using only half of
the exits they conduct tests under
conditions meant to simulate real life
but experts say the tests often fall
short of replicating real accident
conditions it's only when you have a
real accid like this that you get to see
exactly how that that works for the a350
there are four pairs of exits so there
are eight exits on the aircraft so the
certification test would have been done
with four exits now in the a350 accident
at hanada we didn't have four exits we
had three exits and we had two exits in
the front so you're going to have lots
of people trying to use that front exit
this is a
suboptimal evacuation situation experts
say the Japan Line's crew did an
impressive job to evacuate under
difficult conditions flight attendants
asked people to leave their belongings
behind and remove any sharp heels that
might tear the evacuation
shoots welcome on board when you've got
your big roller bag or your big ruck
sack or whatever and you're going down
the aisle you're taking up much more
space than a single person would and so
that's making the congestion worse and
finally if you manage to get to the exit
with the bag and you take the big
luggage down the shoot that can damage
the
slide by 6:05 p.m. 18 minutes after the
Collision the evacuation was complete
and everyone on JL 516 was
safe experts say the design of the
Airbus a350 was also key more than half
of the aircraft was built from carbon
fiber reinforced plastic rather than
aluminum like older planes the Airbus
a350 is the newest Airbus aircraft it
uses a composite fuselage as does the
Boeing 787 what we've seen here is the
first serious event involving an a350 we
know that that aircraft met the design
standards in terms of strength in terms
of how it might deal with a fire when
you look at the fire the aircraft seems
to have done exactly what you wanted to
do which was protect the occupants for
long enough that they could evacuate
from the aircraft Airbus set tests show
that carbon fiber Composites may contain
fire longer than an aluminum fuselage as
it heats up the aluminium loses its
strength and you could get the aircraft
breaking on the tarmak breaking its back
now with a composite fiber it retains
its strength for longer as it's being
heated every second counts every second
can make the difference between life and
death a Japanese transport Ministry of
officials said it was too soon to
determine the cause of the Collision but
a formal investigation would be
conducted Airbus said it was sending a
team of Specialists to help the Japanese
investigators the accident marks the
first total loss of an Airbus a350 since
its first flight in 2013 the a350 is
becoming one of the most popular jets
for Airlines around the
world experts say there are important
lessons to learn from the Hana crash for
anybody flying it's an incredibly safe
method of Transport but when things go
wrong there's a whole bunch of people
who are working to to try and keep us
safe so you know when you get on the
aircraft and you feel grumpy with the
flight attendant that you don't get your
drink quickly enough just remember that
this is a safety professional and in
that incredible evacuation these were
the last people off the
aircraft